des gens vous prennent pour un tueur
vous en êtes un la première fois ça va
te faire mal écoute pas tous ces
connards qui parle de mort
lorsque ça c'est ton histoire c'est que
la fin ce sera ta version
pas une autre un toit c'est ma fille ça
cogne le film offre ferme ta gueule de
bois ici tous partis pourquoi vous
faites ça un droit
ça intéresse qui franchement pourquoi
sont les baisers je te dis moi est
complètement déserte
mais qui va nous cramer assure l'espère
c'est n'importe quoi ton plan [ __ ]
j'en étais très attentivement qui va
faire exactement ce que tout le monde de
faire tu as compris comprends pas qu'on
est mort là mais agir but posthumus
times
je voulais vraiment se mettre à fifa le
juge
mon pire